بدموع وخوف تبكي هذه السيده كلما هلع
طفلاها عند سماع ايه اصوات مجاوره طرقات
خفيفه كفيله باعادتهما الى ويلات حرب لم
ترحم براءه الطفوله نجت عائلتها من
الاقتتال الدائر في الخرطوم وانتقلت الى
بر الامان في القاهره لكن مشهد الموت لم
يغب عن ذاكرتها
سناء واسرتها مثال على شعب استفاق على نار
الاقتتال وبارود الموت
مئه وتسعون طفلا دفعوا حياتهم ظلما في اول
عشره ايام من الحرب
و368 الفا باتوا بلا ماوى ولا تعليم بحسب
اليونيسف
لدينا بالفعل 611 طفلا دون سن الخمسه
يعانون من سوء التغذيه الحادي الوخيمه
ويعاني ثلاثه ملايين طفل دون سن الخامسه
من سوء التغذيه بشكل عام
هذا المكان الذي يقع في مدينه بورسودان
على البحر الاحمر بات ملجا للفارينه من
ضربات الموت امتار صغيره صارت فسحه
ترفيهيه للاطفال علها تمحو ما رسمته الحرب
من مئاس مروعه
[موسيقى]
سواد قاتم يخيم على مشهد الاقتتال المندلع
في السودان منذ اكثر من شهر لكن الواضح ان
اعداد الضحايا والمكلومين اخذتم بالارتفاع
واستخرق تام من الطرفين في حمايه براءه
الطفوله وتوفير متطلبات الحياه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات